one of the hottest new trends which is
really a new version of last decade's
hot new trend and the decade before that
and before that and so on is called
manifesting this is the practice of
trying to get good results by doing
absolutely nothing at all and to engage
in manifesting is to think happy
thoughts and then expect happy things to
materialize for you out of thin air as a
reward it's essentially optimism on
steroids or maybe more like optimism on
hallucinogens and not to skip to the end
of the conversation but the first thing
you should know about manifesting is
that the only thing it actually
manifests is disappointment and failure
here's the New York Post on that quote
manifesting the suddenly trendy practice
of thinking that aspirational thoughts
or ideas will cosmically attract success
might not be as harmlessly woo-woo as
it's hyped up to be those who believe in
the practice of manifesting are at
higher risk of going bankrupt according
to a new study published in the
Personality and Social Psychology
bulletin researchers from the University
of Queensland and Australia also found
that Daydream Believers were more likely
to be lowered into risky Investments and
more apt to Dangerously presume that
they can achieve an unrealistic level of
success in a short amount of time
imagine that quote in our studies we
Define manifestation as the belief that
if you send out your desires to the
universe through positive thoughts
visualization or acting as if goals have
already come true like writing a pretend
check to yourself the universe will
deliver what you desire lead study
author Lucas Dixon told the times UK
this uh appears to be the fundamental
belief that lies behind manifesting
faith that the universe is not only a
conscious entity but one that is
generous and kind and wants us all to be
happy and successful this belief is to
put it mildly misguided and we'll get
back to that in a moment but a little
bit more for the Post report quote
manifestation could lead to people
fixating more on symbolic actions like
visualizing success rather than
instrumental actions such as managing
personal finances those who believe in
manifesting are more likely to feel that
they have control over fairly
uncontrollable aspects of their life
whether they get rich quick or become
famous Dixon said in business this could
lead to an opportunity cost where time
is spent focusing on more uncontrollable
long-term goals rather than controllable
short-term goals
now
that's what manifesting is uh and this
all makes you wonder where this
manifesting stuff is coming from where
what's driving its popularity where are
people getting these ideas well like all
bad ideas of modern society the answer
is mostly tick tock on that platform
countless influencers have manifested
millions of followers for themselves by
promising to give special manifestation
tips tricks and techniques and here's
just one of these videos that has by the
way over a hundred thousand likes very
popular and uh here are the techniques
that she suggests watch
this manifestation method is going to
get you anything you want every time I
do this method I Quantum Leap my life
literally things start manifesting
within 24 hours see most people start
manifesting by saying this is what I
want instead of telling the universe
this is what I want
I tell the universe to show me how
effortlessly this comes to me never
again say I want this because that whole
phrase implies lack I teach you how to
manifest in 30 days here
now watching watching that video I'm
reminded of uh being in third grade or
maybe it was fourth grade at the
beginning of the school year when the
teacher told us to write down our hopes
and dreams for the year on a piece of
paper and she gave us envelopes and told
us to decorate the envelopes with pretty
colors and then we put the paper with
our hopes and dreams into the envelope
and we put our envelopes in a special
box which I think she called our dream
box or open or something like that
anyway even at eight years old I can
remember thinking how pointless and
fruitless the whole exercise was
but based on the popularity of this
manifesting trend it's very troubling to
think that so many adults lack the
skepticism that I had when I was eight
and just so you know I was not a very
smart eight-year-old at all just to be
clear you know before giving our dog
rough greens he was so sad and lazy well
now he actually enjoys his squeaky toys
and playing Fetch with his frisbee our
pup stays are filled with laughter
exercise and endless fun naturopathic Dr
Dennis black the founder of rough greens
is focused on improving the health of
every dog in America little did I know
before I got rough greens dog food is
dead food everybody knows that nutrition
isn't Brown it's green well let rough
greens boost your dog's food back to
life rough grains is a supplement that
contains all the necessary vitamins
minerals probiotics Omega oils digestive
enzymes and antioxidants that your dog
needs you don't have to go out and buy
new dog food you just sprinkle rough
grains on their food every day dog
owners everywhere are raving about rough
grains it supports healthy joints
improves bad breath boosts energy levels
and so much more we are what we eat and
that goes for our dogs too naturopathic
underneath black is so confident rough
greens will improve your dog's health
he's offering my listeners a free jump
start trial bag so your dog can try it a
free jump start trial bag could be at
your door just a few business days go to
roughgreens.com or call 844 rough 700
that's ruffgreens.com Matt or call 844
rough 700 today
now if you spend any time on
manifestation Tick Tock you'll notice
that each manifesting Guru has their own
magical combination of words that's
supposed to lead to health and
prosperity none of them can seem to
agree on what the special phrase is
supposed to be watch
use this one affirmation to manifest
money within 24 hours I want you to
comment down below if you manifest any
sort of money within 24 hours I'm
assured to you that it will work I am
magnetic to money money can't get enough
of me I am magnetic to Money Money
cannot get enough of me
visualize yourself as a magnet drawing
in abundance and wealth because you're a
beautiful being and you deserve to live
an enriching fulfilling life fall off
more monetization tips amount of station
tips
there it is
I guess I'll have to go check my bank
account to see if that worked but I
don't have very high hopes how is this
even supposed to work by the way do you
say the phrase and the money falls out
of the sky does it materialize at a thin
air or are other people with money
suddenly put under some kind of spell
where they feel compelled by mysterious
forces to give that money to you and if
that's it then isn't this kind of a
cosmic form of attempted robbery
I guess that's a sort of ethical
question we talk about if we could get
past the fact that all this is abject
nonsense and we really can't get past
that fact just as one last example
here's another manifestation expert with
um more conflicting manifestation advice
and this one has nearly 200 000 likes
here's what she advises watch
this is the I am sure method you're
going to be penetrating into our
subconscious mind reprogramming it these
three words will instantly align you and
put you into frequency that has the
desire you are now going to affirm out
loud I am sure followed by your desired
manifestation in the present tense for
example I am sure I got the promotion I
am sure Jake texted me read it out loud
10 times now this is even more effective
if you are able to write this out 10
times on a piece of paper till you fall
asleep tonight every single time the
desire pops into your head repeat to
yourself I am sure X this is one of the
methods of the people who are doing my
manifest magic workshop at the top of my
page are using to see results like this
try it out fall for more and make sure
you grab that Workshop
I am sure every tick tock influencer
will float off into space I am sure
every tick tock influencer will float
off into space
I am sure every tick tock influencer
will float off into space
maybe I just saw the tick tock problem
or maybe I accomplished nothing at all I
wouldn't put much money on the former
now you know we aren't going to spend
any more time establishing that all this
is totally Bogus the only thing your
manifestations manifest is more
and we don't need to harp on that
instead I think there are two more
specific points that are worth making
here first manifestation is itself yet
another manifestation of a secular
society's need for religion well we
discover time and time again is that you
cannot really have an entirely
irreligious culture Humanity needs
religion if you chase religion out
you'll you'll be left with a
religion-sized hole that must be filled
and in its place will inevitably be just
a secularized version of what it was
replacing in other words manifesting
is nothing more than a Godless prayer
that is it's a prayer that rejects the
being who can actually answer the prayer
it's a prayer that calls upon the
universe for Aid rather than calling
upon the creator of the universe and the
thing about prayer though traditional
prayer religious prayer is that you
can't treat it like a magical spell it's
not a mystical incantation that will
bring you fortune and fame if you utter
the correct combination of syllables in
Christianity to pray is to lift your
heart and mind to God to lift you know
to look towards heaven to humble
yourself and yes sometimes to ask for
something that you need or want though
that's not the only reason a person
should pray and at any rate the answer
and you know from the Christian
conception of prayer the answer to the
prayer may be no in fact oftentimes it
is and the faithful Christian
understands this and accepts it he also
understands that God expects us to
participate in our own lives he expects
us to work and strive
if we sit around chanting about all the
stuff we want we can be pretty sure that
we won't get anything
but the modern secularist removes all
this from his version of prayer he
removes God first and foremost he
removes humility he removes his own
obligation to act and to work and to
seek and to put in the effort and what
we're left with is an entirely
self-centered exercise in futility
calling out to nothing and nobody
demanding that you know what you don't
deserve and refuse to work for
and that's because and here's the second
important point if you are telling the
universe what you want
you are talking to empty space
the universe doesn't care about you the
universe doesn't know you exist
the universe doesn't know anything
because it has no mind it is big dumb
violent terrifying
the universe would destroy you and the
planet you live on without thinking
twice
because it doesn't think at all the
universe is indifferent
this is the reality we have to just
accept we live in an indifferent
Universe the universe itself is
indifferent
it is not going to make fortune and fame
fall out of the sky for you it'll give
you nothing from the sky but maybe rain
and it will usually be more rain than
you want or not as much as you need
because the universe doesn't care what
you want or need that's the cold reality
it is a reality as cold as the universe
itself which by the way is about
negative 450 degrees Fahrenheit on
average
what does this mean it means that if you
want someone to love and care about you
you need to pray to God not a big empty
space
it also means that even if you pray to
God you still need to work towards your
goals
nothing wrong with having big
aspirations but you need to be willing
to slave away day after day dealing with
all the frustrations and minutia in
order to actually make those aspirations
manifest into something tangible the
manifestation is something that you do
yourself you make them manifest
if you aren't willing to do that then
you'll just be a loser Whispering sweet
nothings to yourself accomplishing
nothing and becoming nobody
that's what manifesting will get you
and it's why manifesting is today
manifestly canceled
thanks for checking out this video if
you'd like to listen to my full podcast
on the go you can check out the Matt
wall show on Apple podcast Spotify or
wherever you get your podcasts